[Music]
when Disney slap frozen's name on a
short film to squeeze more cash under
their biggest hit honest trailers had
the perfect excuse to slap frozen's name
on a video to squeeze more views out of
our biggest hit frozen fever
remember frozen sorta right since the
Big D couldn't make a sequel quickly
enough prepare for a glorified music
video that's trying to beat the clock
before your kids grow out of their
frozen phase now available on blu-ray
for 20 bucks no that is it daddy is done
spending money on this frozen crap
stop crying we're poor now remember
stand-alone princess stories like
Cinderella Snow White and Sleeping
Beauty Disney doesn't as we shamelessly
returned to Arundale for less time than
it takes to listen to free bird all your
favorite characters are back in the
exact same locations to cut down on
costs and rendering time as down--so
lead you by a string on a tour of
various frozen merchandise full of
not-so-subtle callbacks to the original
movie and catchphrases so forced they
would make schwarzenegger blush i don't
get colds besides witness the exact
moment when the filmmakers gave up on
having Elsa's ice powers make any kind
of sense in a scene where she can move
flowers with her mind change the color
of people's clothing and create
out-of-control ravenous sentient
life-forms proving once and for all that
arendelle will be a safer place if they
lock this dangerous witch up in her ice
tower what she's a minute so experienced
frozen without the story stupid rule
rock thingies or good music featuring
one long rambling tune that definitely
won't take the place of let it go
wait wait stop the music don't even
bother we're not singing this one you
probably haven't earned it anyway story
the following reasons Disney needs to
keep frozen relevant and upcoming
Broadway show a new theme park
Olaf ducked a bud Weiss tiny jeep
wranglers chicken soup perfume
multivitamins bullying personal checks
this weird styling head and horrifying
snow cone machines you do realize you're
eating Olaf's intestines while he
watches right frozen reminder do you
remember when Disney actually tried to
hide the innuendos in their films
because those things look like chubby
little do be sure to subscribe for more
honest trailers people die when they are
killed not in the face
not in the face oh yeah you got to get
schwifty you got to get swifty in here
it's time to get swifty i had a little
baby brother and he was perfect perfect
in every way
Rorschach's journal October 12 1985
tonight a comedian died in New York
bubble-blowing goofy goobers